so 2004 was it that you were living in
Venice Beach California and you saw some
Hooper's on the beach I think it was a
little later i think it was around 2006
and I knew some people that were really
getting into whooping they had crazy
names like who polishes and hoop girl
and you know hoop love and and the names
have only gotten better and you know
they there's nothing better than who
publishes there's nothing but they've
gotten longer yeah and they identified
as Hooper's you know it is like what's a
Hooper and how could this be this
important to and be making you feel this
much better they truly seemed happier
they were often starting to make a
living connected to this and they looked
better you know they were physically in
better shape and they really were part
of a community they had a lot of support
systems and I was just fascinated by it
and they were already starting to
document themselves shootin hoop moves
is a huge part of the culture you put
stuff up on YouTube you learn from
someone else they were documenting their
performances you know so way before I
started this movement had a record and
I've met some documentary filmmakers
recently who they'll only make movies
where everything's already shot for them
because they start before a certain year
people weren't shooting so unfortunately
I wasn't that lucky but it helped a lot
you know that you guys had really
documented you know stuff up to now so
we could see the beginning and how lucky
to be living somewhere where a new
subculture is emerging because that's
the most interesting time to film it and
I mean I think the movie is really great
because it's about whooping but it's
also really great because you see the
workings of how a subculture evolves and
this was a subculture a lot jump-started
by women and it's still a lot happening
because of women and in its very very
inclusive which is interesting you know
that women would start something that is
inclusive meaning everybody can hoop and
it just a vibe that the subculture has
you want a hoop you're part of the
subculture you know it's not hard to
become a member
um and there's just so much in our lives
aren't very welcoming and so you know i
never made a documentary film before but
you had to make it you know it required
you to be part of it and so my way of
being part of it is telling stories but
I got a lot of help from the Hooper's
you